on this episode I just bring it
[Music]
yeah
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 168
let me ask Gary Vee show it is very
another very but it is early on a
Wednesday Wednesday morning feeling
pretty good got a little busy yesterday
so sorry I couldn't jump in and do the
show decided bring the Thank You economy
next to me today because I was looking
at some data it's super interesting to
me that the book that I would tell you
is probably the most DNA foundational of
why I've had success in my life is the
book that has sold the least in my
trilogy soon to be a fourth business
book I find that fascinating and I've
been like kind of like in a Zen zone of
like huh doesn't that actually answer
everything I don't know I've got I've
got some interesting thoughts on that
I'm starting to percolate in my brain
about do people not want to execute on
the hardest part of the equation that
brings the most upside I find it
fascinating though maybe I punted the
marketing of Thank You economy a little
bit because it was just as I was
becoming CEO vaynermedia so that might
be part of the equation as well but so I
was want to sort of walk by that this
morning as we set up here also India's
India's train is late so we have a
stand-in Daniel why don't you tell the
Vayner nation uh who you are what you do
I'm Daniel and I'm the Associate
Director of Finance here at vaynermedia
basically I'm in charge of all the
finance for all
Gary's offices around the country under
the CFO of course also a big Knicks fan
yeah which I'm coming budget are you
going tonight yeah me might no good all
right Dana so let's get into the show
you ready yeah big shoes to fill yeah I
know India has lost practice yes
Bernadette asked hey Gary Vee I want to
relocate do I just pick up and move or
do I throw caution to the wind or wait
till I line something up Bernadette I
think um you know the truth is I need a
little bit more context to answer that
question can I see her picture maybe
that can give me a little context oh no
it's some sort of interesting I
on but I think it comes down to
responsibilities where you are in your
life age group you know I really do
think that if you're under 30 everything
should be in play you should you should
sleep in the subways of you know
Singapore like you should live in a rock
you should you know not eat for a year
but not die you know like everything
should be in play under 30 because there
is no reason to disproportionally deploy
practicality under 30 because of how
long people are going to live on on how
much that's an incredible time in your
life and I would absolutely if you're
under 30 just pick up and go especially
if you're not prima donna see one of the
great advantages of being an immigrant
as I think about the book that I may
want to write one day I wish everybody
was an immigrant
one of the main chapters is lack of
entitlement or no prima donna gear right
like last night my mom and dad went out
to dinner with me we were at an event
and we walked through the rain with like
no umbrella and we were just laughing
like we just looked at each other as
everybody else in this kind of New York
City gala was like umbrellas and ubers
and Don't Tell and we just kind of
looked at each other like Belarus you
know like it's just there's nothing
that's kind of sacred everything's
pretty ghetto meaning that if you're
able to wear that like sleep in a crappy
hotel or at your friend's couch or if
you're just not if you're just not in
need of cozy things well then of course
you should pick up and go because you
could work at McDonald's and live in a
[ __ ] and be happy if that's what's
pulling at you if you need certain
things to function as a human like a
clean bathroom or or you know coziness
then then it becomes harder for you to
pull it off so I think that the graph is
really completely predicated on what you
need to function for me I need nothing
to function literally it's so damn scary
and so everything's in play when it
comes to that kind of extreme because I
can go to zero I I know what it's like
to live on a small budget
I don't need fancy things I can wear the
same four pieces of clothes
was on rotation for three years you know
so I just think it comes down to you and
your ability to grind and the truth is
and I've been speaking to a lot of
people about this issue over the last
year most people like to say they can
grind but they don't so that's on you
Lewis ass how do you handle price
projections when attempting to close the
sale
I assume price objections mean that
you're asking for too much money and
they and they don't they don't want to
pay that what's your take on that you
know it's not an easy show you know just
come in like get to like read and like
check out yes I'm very sure um I guess I
would say with you give them a dollar
value and they kind of like how we do
here when we give statements of work
decline when they prove it yeah come
back with you know request to take down
or yeah get tired do they ever do they
have a request to like charge them more
sometimes I ask for more things now we
do change orders and you do have more
money though I love it uh look I think I
think it's moments in time early on when
I was building Boehner and I needed the
leverage of clients and logos to tell
people like yes it's not just I did it
for myself in my family business I do it
for at the time Campbell's the NH L
Pepsi that mattered and so I was willing
to take less we've talked about spec
work and nausea if you watch a show the
d-roc story so I think it's a leverage
game right like who has the leverage and
so I think that um every transaction has
its own cadence there is no blanket
statement here you have to understand
what your product is worth but you also
have to think and this is where people
get again this is what romance kills
people you say that you're worth $150 an
hour and you don't quantify that you
need this client right now because there
isn't good deal flow or you want to buy
some you want to buy a ring for your
girl or you need more loge you need to
do different things besides just shoot
weddings because you want to show a
better portfolio to get other business
people are not using other variables and
they go well I'm worth a buck fifty you
you're worth a buck fifty in your head
the market decides what you're worth
your work a buck fifty if people pay you
a buck fifty consistently always always
and forever
you're not worth that look there was two
years ago where I prematurely tried to
raise my speaking fee higher
it was like that's great Gary and you're
the best speaker ever in this an app but
that is just not where your price is at
and so you are not entitled to anything
other than what the people that are
buying your stuff agree to what you need
to be smart about is understanding when
is the right time to the Gaucher down
because it's in your vested interest or
when are you negotiating down for no
reason at all and you're declining your
value that's on you that's being a good
salesperson that's being a good operator
so I think everybody here needs to have
a balance of both you have to pull from
opposite directions when is it in your
vested interest and then you deploy
humility kool-aid at scale right the
amount of times I will deploy humility
in a world where my ego is on fire is
often you know what Stefan how about
fire here ego fire give me ego fire I've
got nothing but ego and bravado but
there's plenty times I deploy humility
because that's what that moments game
needs to be successful and so I would
tell you to not deploy romance this is
this in a deploy practicality of the
moment Nick meter once did you like that
one yeah it felt like I feel like you
gave me a quick little look I are going
wait you see the way stuff on editing
are you gonna watch it this is an
interesting question
yeah don't lie yeah he does my so if
human and AJ go to the Dallas game
because I got my dad tickets for
Christmas I want him to meet up with you
guys he thinks that you're so awesome
what's your dad's name Tony hey Tony
two things one thank you for thinking
that I'm awesome I think you're awesome
because of number two I adore your
daughter you instilled real work ethic
in this one and that I respect thank you
you're welcome good Nick ass it's lonely
as an entrepreneur sometimes how do you
cope with that feeling you know for me
I'm built for it I want to be lonely I
want to like struggle and grind and have
all the pressure I'm gonna take the last
shot in the game always every time you
know it makes me simpatico with you know
stefan's you know I you know Kobe the
Black Mamba who's on this amazing like
it was funny I was working out this
morning and I had to do like some cardio
stuff that was hard for me so I'm like
Mike put on TV
I can watch SportsCenter not think about
what we're actually doing and I caught
the clip of like the way
Kobe last night in Philadelphia and I
was like you know and I said to Mike I
said you know what's so awesome about
sports is if you time it right and you
know it you can have this kind of
farewell tour something thing about my
farewell entrepreneur tour I don't know
how to do that I'm gonna be like 89 97
but like a hey you know but I you know I
think that I don't remember the question
I just want to talk about Kobe's
farewell tour visit us again Oh being
lonely look the reason brought up Kobe
is Kobe wants to take the last shot
winners want to take the last shot you
want to take the high with the low when
you are truly an a an actual purebred
entrepreneur you don't know anything
else than getting the accolades or
getting [ __ ] on when you don't execute
actually for the first you know it's
really interesting I had a hundredth of
a second because I'm concerned about
macroeconomic climates for a hundredth
of a second yesterday which is unheard
of for me I was like whoo what if like
Vayner took a step back and I had to
deal with like people thing like oh yeah
you're not running this business well or
what's going on like it was so funny I
thought of it for a hundredth of a
second and then I got so happy I got so
happy because I quickly thought about
the second chess move which was for
whatever reason if you know a couple of
our clients as you know are starting to
become very big clients and I don't like
them being too much a percentage of my
business because they can go away the
next day I don't like that so that may
be why popped up in my mind or I also
think we're in a bubbly kind of world
you've got terrorism activity you got
Wall Street being too bubbly for a long
period of time anything can happen
things can happen and so it was funny
for me when I thought about it because
that's my job I'm lonely at the top I
have to worry about everything and make
sure I'm hedged and ready and mentally
prepared for anything that could go
wrong and then I got excited about the
second chess move which was the thing I
live for which is the I told you so when
the doubters came and said oh why did
you miss played it you didn't think
social wasn't as big as you thought you
didn't see this coming then being able
to navigate through those choppy waters
I often talk about being a wartime
general over a peacetime general anybody
can look good anybody who's watching or
listening this show could be an
entrepreneur right now because [ __ ] is
good when it gets tough when there's not
people throwing around $25,000 investor
when when you keep put up your idea on
Kickstarter and everybody wants to give
you a hundred bucks because the
economy's crap and they need their
hundred bucks that's when the cream
rises and so for me the way I deal with
it I the way I deal with it is there is
no D
with it it is my DNA it is my only known
gear I don't even understand that damn
question now I recognize it to take
myself out of the equation and try to
answer for the whole look you got to put
things in perspective you know if you
want the accolades if you have the
audacity to want to be somebody that is
successful make Duty if you want the
let's play the data if you want the
audacity to be a millionaire which is by
percentage almost impossible there's a
very few of them if you really break
down like let's play some math here
let's keep it let's keep it unemotional
let's keep it if you want the audacity
to be in the top and top 1% of Americans
who are is a which is a very rich
company company country probably company
to country are people in the hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year in revenue
not millions so we're talking about a
very small group of people that are able
to get to this extreme level of success
in business and we can have shows about
you know actually know what I was going
to point in India Danielle tell India
when you do a show about like life and
not business stuff but like in the
context of business like life happiness
like there's a million ways and we rant
it on the other day but if you want the
audacity to be a millionaire to be
successful to right folks if you want
the audacity don't you understand the
crap that comes along with that like I
wanted the audacity to be in shape it's
come with a lot of crap it's been a lot
of work I'm eighteen months in and I'm
like I said this the other day I'm not
on my fitness video I'm not sure I would
do this if I saw what I would look like
eighteen months later meaning I look a
lot better but Damon I would be like
really for every single day for 18
months to wake up at 4:00 in the morning
you know like I was like no no you know
so you deal with it because it's a very
small price to pay for all the
phenomenal stuff that you headline read
and you aspire to a new dream for the
problem is most of you don't want to eat
that [ __ ] to get there
Austin asks hey Gary Vee I'm a sales
consultant for Best Buy selling
computers what advice can you give me to
be a better salesman Austin I think you
need to reverse engineer who you're
selling to so if I were you Austin
I would spend all of January taking
people out to lunch and dinner or a
drink or getting them on the phone but
literally spending the entire month of
January not selling to people and just
listen to the people that you sell to to
figure out what their pain points are I
would walk in and be like hey Dirac you
know I sell you computer stuff and
things that nature
what are your pain points what's your
problem what's your struggles in your
business like let's let's cut the crap
like yes I want to sell to you but let's
take a step back I want to sell to you
by providing you some sort of value
maybe I have a friend maybe I will
recommend that you watch the askgaryvee
show to make your business better maybe
I will do a lot of things but what I'm
doing is I'm providing value and our
conversation and our relationship is not
just predicated on me sell you know it's
kind of like I was talking to one of my
friends he's like I want to have better
relationships with girls I'm like cool
why don't you make it something about
other than sex like if your whole
relationship is like I want to hang out
with you every time to just hook up
there's probably a good chance that
person doesn't think that you're
providing them much value outside of
that execution which is a fine execution
everybody needs it I get it la blaw same
way I think about sales if you're just
selling every single time that is what
your foundational relationship is based
on and you become spam and sales all the
time
why don't you spend all of January not
selling ever once and opening your ears
and listening and trying to help even
outside of the context of you even out
of they outside the context of you
meaning how can you help them besides
just their business maybe you'll get to
know the rock and find out that his aunt
is a huge Dallas Cowboys fan and you
just get a Dallas Cowboys hat say hey
you go to eBay and buy a you know a Tony
Dorsett openned starting lineup for 49
cents three dollars shipping but you
send and say hey give this to your aunt
it's not what you spent it was the
thought that stuff matters that's it
great good show thanks Dee um question
of the day when's the last time you
deployed a long period of time of
providing value to somebody else and
then tell the story in the comments
Facebook YouTube on what it meant to
your world maybe it was friendship maybe
then lead to business but you know just
like my latest post on Instagram when
you give you have to also equally deploy
zero expectations in return
ever ever ever like you have to do it
and you have to basically say I will get
nothing for that
yes karma and good stuff will happen but
you can't do it on an individual basis I
can't think that all the value I want to
provide Stefan means that Stefan's gonna
pay me back one day it might be the
story that Stefan gave to Rick that Rick
told Sally that led to something that's
how real life works stop making [ __ ] so
transactional you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering now Stefan were they
saying that the show was really tight
and strong they were and hey good stuff
are you hiding on the show in my candle
I got like 500 new Instagram followers
off of it when you said that I take
selfies in that video that you shad me
out
really yeah got a bunch of creeper dudes
um I don't know because I didn't follow
them back right I didn't get any creepy
comments but I do in search of new power
good you like that that was fun for the
vanity yeah you know yeah oh I dunno I
asked you for a double tap in real life
not Posen Ida I know I don't I don't I
don't like talking about my my suit pics
so much though some of the manor
employees put up some of the pictures
really good pictures with Jeff and I
think Hanna mark yeah thanks cool thank
you thanks your help hey guys um what's
my Twitter or the public identity there
brother
yeah yeah I don't think hey thanks guys
thank you so much for watching the show
thank you so much for jumping on the
scope this early in the morning
um yeah you're getting chirp uh Charlie
it's okay India what's that it's okay
that's all right
Danielle jumped in yeah and she didn't
nice job yup kid what's the law saying
today no laws for head counsel um cool
did you get all this I want this in the
black and white of the other show see ya
see ya
[Music]